poll credibility problem here isn't that
because one of the other things you said
and you repeated it again this week
yesterday I think you said we're not
going to raise v80 you said exactly the
same thing before the last election we
have no plans to raise dat you said it
to my face twice at the time of the last
election and then the moment you got
into government you did raise baat
well there's a crucial difference on
this occasion we are the government
we've been able to look very carefully
at the books we know what is necessary
in the next parliament and our plans do
not involve a tax increases on v80 or
national insurance or or income tax it's
very clear about that we know what needs
to be done and let me explain because I
think people watching at home want to
know what is the scale of what needs to
be done we need to save for the next two
years one out of every hundred pounds
that the government spends now I think
it is the right approach to try and find
one pound of waste in a hundred pounds
of government spending rather than to
put up everybody's taxes which is what
my political opponents want to do so you
got a choice bear down on waste and get
public spending under control or put up
taxes with my opponents that's the
choice but again you said one thing and
you did another what we said that the
most important task for the government
was to get the economy growing which to
Gary's job is he throwing and was to get
the deficit down and I would say on any
analysis and we've had to take we have
had an appalling inheritance we
inherited a situation where Britain's
budget deficit was forecast to be bigger
than Greece's now we had to take
difficult decisions I will defend all of
those decisions difficult ones ones that
were hard to take but the right thing
for the country and the result that
there's a connection between the
difficult decisions we had to take and
the fact that we now have the fastest
growing economy of any major Western
economy we've created two million
private-sector jobs we've got 750
thousand or more businesses the British
economy is working now we need to make
sure that people can what I want is an
economy it doesn't just look good on the
page I want people to feel that they can
get a job they can have a livelihood
they can buy a home they can get a good
school place for their children and
enjoy a retirement those are the things
but that's what
what this plan Jeremy is is all about
spirit of transparency